voilà le mouton noir alors maintenant
nous allons peut-être faire plus ample
connaissance avec la co vedette de ce
film alice et hélène rollès je peux te
tutoyer encore tu as quel âge 12 ans tué
de la sarthe du mans du monde tu vas
encore lisse et bien sûr par comment tu
as rencontré jean pierre masquart dont
ça s'est passé comment une annonce dans
paris match
une article un article qui demandait
donc déjà de se présenter pour un film
oui mais qui a lu l'article c'est toi
c'est ta grand mère qui habite à
mortagne
c'est ta grand mère a téléphoné ça
s'appelle marouani d'un grand mère c'est
à grand mère qui est tombée sur
l'article de paris match elle appelé est
a dit ma petite fille tu veux faire du
cinéma c'est le moment était parents
ont-ils dit ils sont d'accord c'est pas
s'est passé comme ça jean pierre est
venu près 40 1,58 brice est un moment
donné me dit on trouvait pas et brice
est un moment donné me dit ma écoute y
en a une dont couloir prend la vie on
l'a fait rentrer et on l'a fait rentrer
lui donna ses analyses et puis c'était
pas mal
alors
moment donné je l'accuse je l'accueille
la culbute en train de la questionner et
on me dit tu sais que tu as l'air date
qu'on voit là comme ça toujours bon dos
au plateau et aimerait maintenant faire
ce métier je sais pas si ça se
représente c'est jamais mais a demandé à
marie dubois je pensais la bonne
disposition
alors jacques le savait déjà
fidélité le connais plus déjà
[Musique]